[Music]
hey everybody
my name is melisha mcgregor and today
i'll be talking to you
about making vr more interesting with
javascript and brainjacks
so i'm a developer advocate at conducto
where we make cicd tools and if you want
you can follow me on twitter at flip
coding
so to get started i'll give you a
background
on vr
then we'll actually make a small vr
app then we'll go
over a little bit of background on
machine learning mainly neural networks
and then we'll actually add the machine
learning code to the vr app
then we'll go over a few other
considerations when you're working with
a vr
application and then we'll just go
through some key takeaways
so just to get started with a little
background on vr
it's a relatively new area of tech
just because the hardware has been more
recently created
but the applications for virtual reality
span across
all kinds of industries from training
medical students
to video games to different forms of
entertainment
and so this leads to a different career
path that developers can take
it doesn't matter if you know c c sharp
or javascript
you can find a place for you in vr
and then as this hardware starts to
improve you'll notice that virtual
reality is
getting more momentum as something that
companies
are looking to invest in so that's where
we
get a lot of the different career
opportunities
but this is the fun part so we're gonna
go through a live
demo of how to make a vr app
okay so one thing that might be
surprising
is that you just start with an html file
this is the a-frame library so
all you have to do is import the code
here
just in the script file like anything
else
and we also import another package
that gives us access to some pre-made
environments
because when you're working with the vr
application
you need different assets in the world
that you create
and those take a lot of time and
different skill sets
so when you can take advantage of a
pre-made package
it's okay to do that and then we have a
few
other javascript files that we'll talk
about a little bit later
but just so you know how a vr
application
works it's just like a web application
but with different kinds of tags so
you'll see we're just inside
the body but a-frame uses these
different
a tags so when you're working on
a vr application you'll have a scene
and basically what this is is everything
that is
in your vr world
but the first thing you do in a scene is
import all of the assets that you want
to use
so in this case we have a few jpegs that
we're going to make
into textures for the different objects
we put in the world
and i did have music for this game but
once i realized this talk was going to
be recorded i don't think you want to
hear that
playing over and over again but if you
want it to include music you just use
the audio tag like you would in any
other javascript project
so we have our assets that means it's
time to start
putting objects into the vr world
and the first thing we're going to put
in there is just a box
just a regular box and
what makes this one kind of special is
that
if you see here the source is actually
the same
as this wooden texture asset that means
that this block is going to look like a
piece of wood
and this attribute is the height of the
object
so in a frame you can set different
attributes
on these a tags and they determine
how the shape is built inside of the
world
so in this case our box is going to have
a height of 3 meters because a frame
measures
everything in meters and then
it's rotated a little bit around the y
and the z
axis just to show you something
different
in the world and here you'll see the
position this one is really important
because this is exactly where
the object is going to be in the world
so this means that it's going to be
37 meters in the x
direction it's going to be one meter off
of the ground
and then it's going to be 37 meters
in the z direction behind us so
that's how the positioning works with a
frame
and another attribute is this animation
position
basically what this does it lets you
customize animations on objects
so what we're doing here is taking the
property that we want to animate for
this block
and we're saying we want to change the y
position to 2.2 meters
every two seconds so that means this
block will just float
up and down between one meter and 2.2
meters
and then the last thing here for
attributes is this custom attribute
so this is one that we'll talk about as
soon as we're done
in this file and if you'll notice there
are some just primitive shapes here so
you can use
boxes spheres cylinders
they're all built into a frame
but down here we have something just a
little bit different
this is a plane and all that is is just
it's just a plane it's like having a
sheet of paper
that you can make magically float in
your world
and what we've done with this plane is
just
write down a few of the things that we
want
the user to find in the game that we're
making
and to do that we use the base
a-frame tag which is a entity and you
can
set which kind of primitive
shape it should be with an attribute so
in this case
we just wanted text because it's a list
of items
that the player needs to find in the
game
and it's right at the beginning where
they can see it so they don't need to
walk around to find it
then down here we get to another entity
which has the environment
and that is what really makes the layout
for your world
so that library we imported in the
beginning
it's responsible for building a world
based on these different attributes
which you'll get to see in a few seconds
but the last thing that i want to show
you before we get into the game
is probably the most important part of a
vr
application and that's the camera so
where you position your camera changes
the entire gameplay
for a user and that could be
you put the camera behind them so that
they can see themselves walk around
you can make it into first person view
so that it looks like
you're just looking around in the game
or you can do
any kind of camera positioning that
makes sense for what you're making
but what we have here is just a camera
that's slightly behind the user so it
looks like a first person view
and we've added just a little ring to
the center of the camera
so that as the user moves around they
can determine
what they're looking at so
now let's just go ahead and
run this app
so it should be running
it takes a little while for a frame to
load sometimes
but it's a really good library to get
started with
now you see this is the environment that
we imported from that library
and we have our list of things we can
look around
walk around and maybe find something
i'm not sure exactly where it is right
oh
i think we found some hey
so we found this object and
when you click on it that sends it back
to the starting position because you're
collecting these
so the way that that works is in this
found
item this is that custom attribute that
we briefly mentioned earlier
and whenever you want to make a specific
action for a vr object this is how you
do it in a frame
so whenever you click on one of the
objects you're looking for in the game
it goes to a specific position
back at the starting point and that's it
so back to the presentation now
that you have seen the vr app we'll talk
a little bit about machine learning
so neural networks are a form of machine
learning algorithm
and they're just used to make
predictions
so a neural network is made of layers of
nodes
because it's supposed to try to
represent what the brain is like
and basically you give it a set of
inputs
you assign some weighted values to it to
highlight the importance of each input
and then the neural network goes and
makes different connections and
assumptions
and gives you an output so
you've probably heard of deep learning
before and
all this is is just a neural network
with multiple nodes
so if you have two nodes in your neural
network
you're doing deep learning already
then a little bit about the library that
we'll be using which is brain js
and i'm sure you've heard of tensorflow
but there's a few reasons that i chose
brain.js
over tensorflow first it's a lot
easier to use i'm not sure if you looked
at their documentation but you have to
learn
a lot of new terminology and a lot of
new things when you're using tensorflow
where with brain js if you know how to
work with
objects and arrays it's really easy to
get started
then with brain you also don't need as
much background in machine learning
as long as you have your data and you
know which
algorithm you want to use you don't have
to know about the math or anything else
behind it
you just know have to know which methods
to call
and then the tutorials for brain.js are
really straight to the point and easy to
follow so if you go through their
tutorials you'll find out you have a few
really cool useful projects at the end
and
to get into a machine learning project
there are a few things you need to do
when you're choosing features or those
inputs for each of the nodes
you have to ask what will add the most
value for a user
so that means is it something that's
going to make
their experience better or is it
something missing that they've been
asking for you just want to make sure
that
whatever features you choose are going
to lead to a prediction
that adds value for the user
and then ask how do you get the
information you need from a user
do you ask them for it do you have them
fill out surveys do you data mine them
while they're
using their web browser how are you
going to get the information you need
to get those features
and then this is a really important
question you should ask in the beginning
what are you trying to predict with all
of the information you get from a user
so that's the point of the machine
learning problem is you're trying to
make a prediction
based on previous information
and then one that we probably run into a
lot with just
javascript and web apps in general is
will the user
actually care if we make this kind of
update
that kind of goes back to what adds the
most value for a user
because even if it does add value
if they don't care then you might want
to
consider if it's worth all of the work
and effort
to build this model to make predictions
for that
so make sure that any changes you make
or any predictions you're trying to make
are things that a user will care about
when you apply them
now we get to go back to the fun part
and do some more coding
and we'll add machine learning to this
app
so back in the html file
i wanted to show you a property on one
of these objects called
cursor listen so whenever we
find this box this
function will get triggered so cursor
listener
basically just calls a function on the
back end
to get a new predicted position for all
of the
remaining objects and what's happening
here
is that it imports this user model
and when it gets called
it goes to this backend api and it sends
back
the users x y and z position
how many steps they've taken and whether
they found an item or not
and what that does for us is on the back
end we get to make our machine learning
app
so if you're familiar with nodejs at all
this is just an express app so we import
all of our libraries and packages we set
up an express
app and do some regular use stuff
but down here is where we get into the
machine learning
so this is our initial training data
and basically these are values that
we've gotten from
users over time right this is
their current position right here
and whether they found the item or not
which would be the box
and how many steps they've taken in the
game so far
so as you see this is just an array of
objects for our data
that's all then we have to have
our initial training data output
so based on these inputs we're
trying to predict how likely a person is
to finish the game
and usually when they've taken more
steps they haven't found an item
and they're really far away from the
initial position
they have a lower likelihood of
finishing the game
which you can see with this array of
objects
so we have our initial input data we
have our initial output data
so we put them together into a single
object that we'll use in the brain.js
library
so this training set is just a
combination of our input
and output arrays
now that we have all the training data
this is probably
one of the best parts is building the
model
so with brain.js it's super easy to
build a neural network
this is it this is the one line of code
that it takes
to make a neural network in practice
and all this is it just has three hidden
layers
which is how you add a little bit more
complexity
to some of the connections that the
neural network makes as is trying to
get a prediction based off of the
features you chose
so we have our model here
and then this is definitely the best
part you get to train the model with the
data that you have
and all it takes is one method call
so we made the model up here and you
train it
just by calling the train method and
passing it
the training data set that's all we have
trained
a neural network to make predictions
of whether a user will finish the game
or not
based on how they've been moving around
so far
so all we've done here is
when brain.js runs the train method
it collects statistics around how many
iterations it took to get the final
value
and how the error rate decreases with
those iterations
and then we just do a quick run to see
if
the model works that's all this is here
so
we trained it we got our statistics on
how well the model trained
and then we tested it so now we know
that this model
is ready for user play
so we've set up just a simple backend
api and all it does
is gets the data from the user
which if you remember that happens right
here
so we just get the position of the
objects
and then we take
the position of everything and move it
around
based on the likelihood of a user to
finish the game or not
so if the user is more likely to finish
the game
we'll move the object further away to
keep them playing longer
and if they're less likely to finish the
game we try to move the objects closer
to them so they'll find one
and keep playing and finish it
then at the very end of this call we
just send the new position
back to this to the items that are still
on the playing field and they'll move
around
accordingly that's all
for the machine learning part so
hopefully you see that
machine learning doesn't have to be
really hard or really complicated
it just depends on what you're trying to
do and which libraries you need to use
so now that you've seen the vr app in
action and you've seen how machine
learning integration works
there's a few other considerations first
off
is the overall user experience
everything you design for a virtual
reality world
should have the user experience in mind
because
they're being submerged in a completely
different environment
you don't want them to feel lost or like
they don't know what they're doing
because
then they'll abandon your app completely
and another thing is that you want to
make sure you're using data
ethically especially when it comes to
machine learning projects
you don't want to take people's personal
data
and do just unethical things with the
like sell it or use it to try to
manipulate them into buying things
so make sure that all of the data you
collect for users
is being used ethically
and then this is a question that comes
up a lot in machine learning
is what's the best algorithm well that
really isn't a
best algorithm overall it depends on
your application
so for example with this we were just
trying to predict whether
a user would finish a game or not that
could have been done with something like
a multivariate regression
algorithm or any number of other
algorithms
is just what feels better for your data
what gives you faster results and what
gives you the most
accurate results those are the metrics
you should use
when you're trying to pick a machine
learning algorithm
and then as much as i love javascript
and brain js
when you get into the bigger machine
learning problems you'll definitely want
to switch to python
just because they have a lot of
different libraries for things like
natural language processing and image
processing and just all of the bigger
machine learning problems
so if you want to do work with
millions of data points python is
probably going to handle it better than
javascript will
and so we want to wrap up with some key
takeaways
it's really important that you try to
combine multiple areas of tech
this is where you get to have fun and be
creative and
make new things that nobody's ever seen
before
so don't be afraid to combine
multiple areas of tech that sound
difficult because that might not be as
hard as you think
and then always always remember the
ethics
surrounding data it's so important that
we keep our data secure
and that we make sure nobody's using it
inappropriately
because i'm sure you've heard in the
news about
data breaches or people using personal
information
to open credit cards or buy things
so you really want to make sure that all
of your data is
always secure and being used
ethically and of course just try
new things it's okay if you don't
understand it at first or if it doesn't
make much sense
but the point is to just try it with
javascript we can do
basically anything from web apps to
robots to machine learning
so don't be afraid to take your skills
and just try new things
and try to learn something that you're
interested in
and it solves a problem you have so with
this vr game that i made
i wanted a really easy game to play but
not too easy so the machine learning
really adds that extra layer of
complexity that i was personally looking
for
and when you start to combine your
interests
with some of your problems you get to
make
really really cool products and of
course is better because
everything is in javascript
so this is all i have to share with you
today
i really really hope that you liked it
and you learned something
and if you have any questions or you're
interested in more of the things i'm
doing
remember to follow me on twitter at
flippedcoding
so thank you for your time